bonjour frédéric viale merci beaucoup
merci d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france
alors on va faire un point sur
l'agriculture britannique post break
zitte le gouvernement a élaboré une
large consultation pour renouveler en
tout cas cette agriculture où près de
plus de 60 % des agriculteurs ont plus
de 65 ans c'est une profession qui est
vieillissante pourquoi tout simplement
parce que comme dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne la politique agricole
commune d'aulnay les subventions à
l'hectare et donner les subventions à la
tête de l'agriculteur qui produisent ou
qu'ils produisent pas et donc à partir
de ce moment là évidemment les
agriculteurs qui reçoivent les
subventions veuille continuer dé
recevoir le plus le plus longtemps
possible et par ailleurs pour daisy pour
des raisons historiques propres à la
grande bretagne
il n'y a pas véritablement eu dans le
passé de révolution chance hier on va
dire ça comme ça pour le dire gentiment
c'est à dire que il ya une forte
concentration du foncier historiquement
en grande bretagne et donc on a un pays
où il ya beaucoup de très grands
propriétaires qui sont par définition
des propos des grands propriétaires
absents et qu'ils conservent leur terre
parce qu'ils sont sûrs de toucher
beaucoup de subventions
on parle souvent de la reine
d'angleterre c'est un des exemples
c'est la première agricultrice en
grande-bretagne voyez figé je rectifie
ces quatre agriculteurs sur dix qui ont
plus de 65 ans l'âge moyen est de 59 ans
il est de 52 ans en france vous le
disiez finalement la pac a eu des effets
pervers de maintenir ces grands
propriétaires terriens en place au
détriment des des petites exploitations
c'est un effet pervers de la pac qui va
se terminer en 2022 puisque les 3
milliards alloués à la grande bretagne
ne seront plus octroyé par l'union
européenne c'est le gouvernement
britannique qui va mettre la main à la
poche
oui bien entendu enfin c'est à dire si
le pays lui même puisque évidemment avec
la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne et bien désormais la
grande bretagne n'a plus à contribuer à
la politique agricole commune c'est
normal puisqu'elle ne fait plus partie
de l'union européenne et donc dès
maintenant en fait ça a été annoncé déjà
en 2020 la grande bretagne le
gouvernement britannique a décidé de
prendre un certain nombre d'orientations
avec avec les subventions qui est
normalement allait à la pac l'avant
aller aux agriculteurs britannique sait
c'est très très logique et donc les
conséquences nocives on va dire où en
tous les cas néfastes de certaines des
mesures de la pac comme par exemple la
subvention à l'hectare ou à la tête
et bien cela va pouvoir s'arrêter en
tous les cas va pouvoir être modifiées
petit à petit par une nouvelle politique
agricole de la grande bretagne
ça ne veut pas dire que les problèmes
vont disparaître comme par comme par
enchantement le problème du foncier d'un
problème séculaire en bretagne ça fait
très longtemps que ça que ça existe et
le gouvernement a décidé de s'attaquer à
ça on va voir si effectivement ce qui va
décider où ce qu'il va faire et
l'efficace vous savez entre le moment où
on commence à faire des annonces en
domaine agricole et aux le moment où il
ya effectivement des réalités qu'on peut
constater sur le terrain il se passe
plusieurs années les agriculteurs
concernés ont plutôt favorablement
accueilli cette mesure la mesure wibp
haïti sont ils sont ils sont favorables
à ça parce que il ya de toute façon un
moment donné dans la vie d'un
agriculteur la question de savoir
comment on passe la main alors quand on
est un très grand agriculteur je veux
dire un très grand propriétaire terrien
le fait de passer la main n'est pas un
vrai problème quand on est un
propriétaire terrien plus petit
qui effectivement est attaché à sa terre
là c'est un problème mais c'est un
problème ici en grande-bretagne
puisqu'on parle de la grande bretagne
mais c'est un problème partout en
réalité et on a le même on a le même
également en france donc le fait qu'il
soit aidé pour passer la main et quelque
chose qu'ils ne pourront qu'apprécier en
effet pervers aussi du maintien de ces
grands propriétaires subventionné par la
pac
selon le gouvernement il serait peu
moins respectueux en tout cas des
contraintes environnementales c'est pour
promouvoir aussi l'écologie que le
gouvernement britannique adopte cette
mesure de toute façon là en 2020 le
gouvernement britannique a fait tout un
tout une série d' annonce avec une
nouvelle politique de subvention qui est
aux alentours de 2800 pardo 2 milliards
800 millions de livres sterling qui sont
des mesures de verdissement des
versements agricoles et notamment
il y a toute une tout un tas de
subventions qui sont prévu désormais
pour les agriculteurs respectueux de
l'environnement qui préserve l'habitat
naturel qui veillent au bien-être animal
qui réduisent l'usagé des pesticides
ça c'est ce qui est annoncé par ailleurs
il ya il reste quand même que on est
dans quelque chose qui pour les
agriculteurs et il ya un certain nombre
de syndicats qui se sont prononcés là
dessus qu'ils disent que la situation
est encore un peu flou qui ne savent pas
trop encore sur quels véritables
critères les choses vont se font se
décider mais en tous les cas du point de
vue de l'annoncé gouvernementale
oui il y a une volonté affichée du
gouvernement de faire plus de
d'environnement mais alors attention il
faut voir maintenant à l'acte
effectivement c'est un gouvernement qui
a un penchant néolibérale tout à fait
prononcer et personnellement je serais
tu
surpris qu'ils arrêtent de mener comme
ça du jour au lendemain des politiques
qu'ils soient vraiment très libérale
comme elles le sont depuis pas mal
d'années en grande bretagne et plus
largement concernant la politique
agricole commune
donc c'est pas facile comme ça de
changer de cap
le gouvernement a dit qu'il le ferait
est-ce que effectivement il va le faire
dans la mesure où il reste avec un on va
dire un tropisme néolibérale ça c'est
pas gagné et on verra cela merci en tout
cas frédéric viale pour votre analyse ce
matin dans la matinale d'ayrté france